dormir sur le dos bon c'est la position
la plus mal aimée et si on regarde comme
ça vite fait bah on peut se dire que
c'est bien mérité dormir sur le dos ça
favorise les ronflements et l'apnée du
sommeil ça favorise aussi le bruxisme
c'est-à-dire le fait de grincer des
dents mais d'un autre côté au niveau du
dos c'est quand même beaucoup mieux
c'est la meilleure des trois tout est
bien aligné tout est bien rectiligne et
si votre matelas est pas trop défoncé la
colonne vertébrale elle est aussi dans
une courbure idéale c'est à dire que ça
évite les tensions les douleurs etc on
est dans une position qui est neutre qui
est assez naturelle donc on est bien pas
de remontée acide non plus ou de
problèmes digestifs tracez quand même
dommage que cette histoire de
respiration sinon on est parfait quoi ah
oui parce que quand on est allongé sur
le dos à plat comme ça toutes les
parties molles tous les tissus mous
qu'on a dans le fond de la gorge ça
vient se plaquer contre l'entrée de la
trachée donc non seulement on respire
pas bien mais en plus ça vibre ça fait
du bruit etc vous connaissez